[Applause]
before we get started on this what
that's new right yeah I just saw that
opening that's a new opening and you
have a different opening I just saw that
that pisses me off that uh that is not
my body no because I'm here all the time
I would have happily put on that costume
it's a blue shirt and some khakis I'd
have put that on instead they got some
sick kid I don't stand like that
that's horrible I just no no
all right where were we oh yeah
info button remote push it and the
little thing comes up we're gonna take a
look at some right now for example I was
watching the daily White House press
briefing the other day yeah just
checking it out and wondering what's
going on so I hit the info button
curious what it would say and I said man
baby who needs a nap speaks for higher
up man baby who needs a nap
did I turn down the show I turned on the
show property brothers I was watching
property brothers and I just want to see
what it said so hit the info button it
said riah real estate reality show
features the most famous brothers who
haven't murdered their parents yet yeah
that's important yeah
CNN I was watching CNN for a little bit
watching some CNN I hit the info button
that said a place your eyes can go while
you wait for the boarding announcement
part of the Turner family right Jeff
will take that one out storage wars I
was watching storage wars yeah watching
storage wars when I hit the button and
it said residents of a 3.8 million
square mile country fight over a 10 by
10 closet that smells like farts
wait Charlie Rose I was watching Charlie
Rose
there's Charlie Rose I'm gonna bono
watch the Charlie Rose and I hit the
button and it said award-winning
journalist investigates his Studios
complete lack of light bulbs dear white
people I was watching the show dear
white people and then I hit the button
and it said this show title is also how
President Trump starts every cabinet
meeting plays we've got to work together
planet earth - I was watching that show
planet Earth - that's an amazing show
beautifully done and then I hit a little
info button it said tune in for the
dramatic last episodes of Earth's final
season yeah oh that oh you don't find
the end of the world humorous do you
that would be your fault not mine hey I
was watching The Handmaid's Tale on Hulu
watching The Handmaid's Tale and then I
hit the button it said tonight on Mad
Men
PEGI continues her struggle to succeed
in a world dominated by men and Don
lands a new ad campaign for bonnets
and finally the walking dead I was
watching The Walking Dead yeah
pretty popular watching The Walking Dead
I hit the info button and it said
tonight
the survivors successfully fight off a
bunch of zombies then the big twist more
zombies
[Applause]
you